google marketing live is one of the
largest marketing conferences in the
world
annually thousands of marketers from all
over the globe travel to the event to
see all the latest developments from
google
in year past google has made several
significant announcement at the event
and it looks like this year will be no
different this video looks at the major
announcement that happened during the
event and how they can help you to use
google products in the future
the keynote mainly focuses on how video
ads are improving automation advances
and a look at future tech here are some
of the major announcements that were
made during the show youtube shorts is
averaging over 30 billion daily views
up 4x from just a year ago
and we're pleased to announce that we're
gradually rolling them out to all
advertisers around the world
starting today we're including shorts as
part of our existing video action and
app campaigns
so let's start with the most important
announcement that you should invest
youtube short ads during its marketing
live event google announced the company
would gradually roll out ads on youtube
shorts around the world as of last year
youtube had been testing ads in youtube
shorts video action campaigns and app
campaigns will automatically scale to
youtube shots
next up is discovery in particular in
moments of discovery a video can convey
so much that's why starting this year
we're testing video ads in the feed on
discovery as an engaging and interactive
experience for our users
now people will be able to engage with
your brand in a more natural and visual
and interactive ways they scroll through
content
looking for ideas and inspiration the
next announcement related to video ad is
video ad coming to discover announcement
of video ads appearing directly in
discover is a great news for video
advertisers
discover currently features many videos
in the feed so this would be an ideal
match discover ads work well with bold
eye-catching images currently and video
should be no different
google audiences in connected tv for
display and video 360.
and the best part this will work across
hulu peacock youtube and other
ad-supported connected tv apps we have
covered the first two major
announcements so let's discuss the third
one google audiences for connected tv
campaigns advertisers will be soon able
to target viewers across youtube and
most other connected tv apps using
connected tv campaigns as a result of
this exciting new development connected
tvs will be able to target affinity in
market and demographic audience segments
these announcements focused on video
advertising now it's time to check the
advancements in automation
to start with we're introducing
experiment tools for performance max
which means you'll be able to run a b
test to measure the incremental uplift
that each campaign is driving
a b testing coming to performance max ai
driven advertising is the future as
jerry disler said advertisers have asked
for more transparency so google is
providing it but the question is what
are they doing to increase transparency
and the answer to this question is the
performance max update offers new ways
to understand how automation drives
results
because you need flexible ways to manage
your performance max campaigns we now
support them in search ads 360 and in
the google ads mobile app
and the next update is that campaigns
will also be supported in search at 360
and google ads mobile applications
this year we're going to give you the
ability to run search and conversion
lift tests including geo experiments
directly in google ads and in display in
video 360.
the next announcement is search and
conversion lift tests
it includes geo experiments and will be
available in google ads and display
video 360 this year our goal is to build
tools you can trust so you are confident
you are properly valuing your ad spend
in the new normal that's why you need a
robust set of privacy safe measurements
options to remain resilient set by
google
before we proceed with the presentation
i would appreciate if you pause the
video and take out 2 minutes to think of
the best announcement out of these six
that will help users to drive more
business
i hope you are done with the comment
let's move forward to our next
announcement that is related to search
ads
later this year we are enabling
responsive search ads to use text
content directly from your landing pages
in your account we will just pull from
all your existing high quality assets to
address a customer's unique search
automation created assets will be
available in responsive search ads
google will be enabling responsive
search ads to use text content from your
landing pages it will pull from all of
your existing high quality assets to
meet a customer specific search needs
today you can use google business
messages and customers can message a
business directly through google search
google maps or even the businesses
website or app and get timely support
google business messages update in the
next few months customers will be able
to message businesses directly from the
search ads currently being tested the
open beta is planned to kick off by the
end of the year
now to help you store source and
organize all of these creative assets we
are making the asset library in google
ads available to all advertisers
it's a one-stop shop that enables you
and your team to import collaborate on
and just organize all your image and
video content
and once the content is imported it can
be accessed wherever you're building
your ad so we discussed the two major
announcement that is related to search
et moving forward we will discuss the
asset library updates so the next
announcement is a set library in google
ads opening to all advertisers
once the content is imported it can be
accessed wherever you are building your
ad whether discovery app display or
performance next campaigns
soon we'll be able to create an
effective video and publish it to
youtube in as little as 60 seconds
directly in the library creating videos
directly from asset library now you can
create videos directly from the asset
library it will help the advertisers to
create more effective ads for customer
behavior on the insights page
now this page is tailored to your
business and it just covers a gamut of
use cases
the next announcement is related to the
insight report over the next few months
google will roll out three new reports
to the inside page see how your ad works
together across google services with
attribution insights find new budget
optimization opportunities with budget
insights and see the impact of your
customers segments on campaign
performance using audience insights
the insights will help users to get a
better understanding of what's happening
in the account as well as the broader
trends but getting all this data is not
enough in order to drive business it
would be best if you acted as well and
here optimization comes into the picture
so now let's understand the announcement
related to the optimization score
announced by google you also want to act
on these insights quickly and actually
drive value for your business
and this is where the recommendation and
the optimization score comes in
and here's why the optimization score
really matters
advertisers who increase their account
level optimization score by 10 points
saw a median 14
increase in conversions
optimization score really helps you
prioritize google will cover all types
of google ad campaigns in the coming
months the optimization score can help
you prioritize the most important
changes to make
through my ad center users will be able
to control how their data informs the
ads they see on youtube
search and discover
the next announcement in the bucket is
my ad center google will allow users to
select the types of ad they want to see
more or less
we're introducing the google tag in the
coming weeks
it'll replace the google global site tag
and allow you to combine your tags and
manage your settings centrally without
additional code and here comes the last
major announcement on the list that is
google tag
as a result the global site tag has
become the google tag and will be
updated with new capabilities
so with this we have come to the end of
the session on announcements from google
marketing live 2022. i hope this session
was informative and exciting in case you
have any question about any of the
topics covered in this session then
please free to let us know in the
comment section until next time this is
tushan from simplyland team signing off
thank you stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here